I'll start with the emergency evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest fire exit the fire
assembly point is the island in front of
the main entrance to the building please
do not delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings please do not return to
the building until G given permission to
do so by the council staff please switch
off mobiles or turn them to silent
please note that the meeting will be
live stream so please remember to switch
your microphone on when
speaking members of the public whilst
you are of course entitled to film or
take photographs during this meeting
this should be done without disruption
to the meeting and can be only done from
a designated area in the public seating
please raise your hand clearly in the
air if you wish to take photographs or
film this
evening no one has done
so right we move on to
the agenda agenda item one apologies for
absence we have an apology from
councelor Daniel belon and understand
councilor W
substituting any other I think everyone
else is here agenda item two non-members
attending none apart from Council W
substituting agenda item
three minutes of the meetings held on
the 20th of September 23 and the 7 of
January
2024 are the minutes
approved there a general acceptance
there thank
you agenda item four to receive
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of
Interest there's no one indicating so we
move on to five agenda it of five in the
first paper on the on the agenda um
Marcus hotton director of environment
will introduce this
report
good evening members um this report is
uh in response to um committee members
raising concerns regarding um the
environmental impact of 3G pitches um as
you can find in report eludes that we
have an opportunity to uh consider
installing 3D pitches within the
district um but I think um in the light
of um the EU ban on the use of certain
microplastics I think the committee
members are that we we we sort of put
this report together I think officers
put together a very comprehensive report
and uh I'm nothing really further to
know but uh so happy to take any
questions thank
you on the uh on the
recommendation which is in is it
51 where is the recommendation so can
you just direct me to it
51 is
5.1
um I find it illogical not to agree with
it I mean it's just common
sense but I just want to query the
phrase strive
to and would it be in order to make that
we should rather than strive
to because it seems to me that the
mitigation measures for using the micr
Plastics are a bit convoluted and I'm
not actually sure that they would be
followed in every case so does that
leave us any alternative but to use the
substitute
materials I think that that's um
obviously just suggested wording I I
think it's the members to consider and
adjust as they see fit I said it's um a
position statement that would course go
on to the executive to consider um but I
suppose as a as a I would suggest as a
climate emergency an ecological
emergency sort committee then then I
guess yes if you're looking for stronger
wording to to make quite clear the
committee's position to the executive
then I said that that's that that would
seem like a sensible wording to to
consider thank
you uh sorry counc I was going to ask if
councelor sharp would to put that
forward as an amendment yeah I would
like to put that forward as an amendment
thank you do I have a
second uh counc Wilson
seconds um then sorry councelor Mill
wanted to come in as well um yeah at the
moment there is um the European Union as
we know is looking at the infill which
is a rubber material made from old tires
um but there's ongoing we I think we
should have an amendment to keep a view
constant review of up andc coming
Research into the actual Turf material
itself because there American papers
from universities and an ecological one
from Europe there actually SI thousands
of cubic uh kilometers of ocean off the
coast of of Europe and found up to 10
15% blades amongst this because it
doesn't rot and the material the turate
of keeps collecting so and the pasas has
chemicals in it which break down in
sunlight and because people are running
and thumping around on this stuff it
doesn't repair itself like grass
and and they there are um concerns about
that at the moment so as that's ongoing
we ought to review this from time to
time because at the moment we'll
probably say it's have 2G because it
doesn't have the rubber crumb and Sport
England say it's okay but the jury is
still out on all of this there there's a
lot of work going on with the
universities on it if you search the
internet you will find the papers and um
from that point of view that's a concern
because of this there's 100,000
of these pitches in Europe and we keep
the
material be buried in the ground so we
keep going and going and going saw these
every 10 years you can see eventually
building up possibly building up some
problem but we do need to have the
science for that which is its early
stages they're Finly I mean I think
somebody vacuumed pitches in America and
found something like 200 kilograms a
year coming out of them of of particle
material which blows around and
eventually gets into the water courses
goes into rivers and because you end up
with these uh Little Bits flying
floating around in the ocean which
scientists have start finally started to
evaluate which there's a paper on their
cier about it um which is quite quite a
piece of work it's say in Europe so I
think we could say
3G we'll go with science on that from
Europe but 2G but we need to keep an eye
on it it's something we ought to review
uh yeah thank you I'd like to recommend
that we we we say that so it's okay at
the moment because that's what we're
being told is
okay I'm not sure how we fit that into
the recommendation at the moment can we
come back to that in a
minute because we're still on the first
recommendation um we we
are it's a bit difficult this I'll
probably take advice how do we if there
are other amendments to the draft
position statement coming forward how do
we deal those should we take them each
separately as they
come yeah I've got a not there so we
we'll do that sorry
marus so I think just
with I think I think the captur of in
the position statement it talks about
seeking
[Music]
um that there are alternatives out there
I think again if you look into the
report at 4.4 we mentioned about
Manchester City Council who in
communication
um have used a a cork infill um and and
we report actually quite successful and
so I think if you're taking a
precautionary principle on this matter
then you you you'd seek not to use the
the microplastic infill um if we have to
delay whilst we are looking for
Alternatives but we're going to come up
with an alternative that we're actually
more that we are satisfied with meets
our criteria sustainable criteria then I
we can proceed but I think it's captured
in there but it is it's a um
it's a sort of area stud it's Prett
infancy it's still coming to light isn't
it but I think that's that's why the EU
have stepped up and said actually look I
think we need to ban this and you know
as a precaution more than anything else
well well I'll be satisfied with that at
a moment okay so with regard to the
um Amendment to the position statement
if we do with that first which has
already been put forward by councilor
sharp and secondly by councelor Wilson
that would change the wording of of is
that any 3G pictures planned for the
district should use sustainable organic
materials is that correct so we removing
the words strive to
yeah is that everyone clear on that so
everyone anyone has any comment on that
any questions or shall we go to the vote
so we go to the vote oh sorry councelor
W yeah thanks chairman um I actually
think the strive uh it does put a lot of
pressure doesn't it if we say should and
use legally that does put a hell of a
lot of pressure on you know whoever is
going to create these to actually do it
I I think strive I know I know what uh
he's saying in regards to it it's a bit
more forceful to say
should it's not as forceful as
must but um
strive I feel probably struck a right
balance in my opinion say that's my
opinion I would prefer to continue with
the word strife but I can understand
that the word should as well as as an
intent thank you okay thank you uh
councelor Mo um well there is the 2G
option um which has a different a
different sort of infill isn't sort of
so environmentally
unfriendly there is that and that may
well um subject to research in the
future for the time being um sort of
satisfy that kind of um
requirement yeah I think we may be
coming to that after the after this vote
thank you so thank you no other first
and got yeah I know yeah I know that so
councelor Wilson was your was yours on
this amendment or on something else
because we're speaking to this amendment
it was a further addition so in in
addition to councelor shops yeah can we
take that after yeah this vote then
because I think we need just need to be
clear on what we're voting on councelor
Williams thank you thank chairman um
actually I prefer the word strive should
sounds a bit ambiguous to me so i' much
rather use the word strive okay okay
thank
you we'll go to the vote then those in
favor of the amendment which will change
the
wording to the district should use
sustainable organic materials those in
favor of that
Amendment
those
against thank you and those
abstaining
right thank
you that's carried as Amendment um I'll
now move on to councilor
Wilson thanks chair so um I propose a
further Amendment to the amended
recommendation um which is to add at the
end of um paragraph 5.1 the words and
that all Alternatives be evaluated
before considering their use so in other
words we don't just reach for uh 3G
pictures but that we have actually
demonstrated that we've considered
Alternatives do you want me to read the
wording again yeah so at the end of of
after it is place and that all
Alternatives be
evaluated before considering their use
thank you and that's seconded by
councelor
mcferson so we go to people anybody who
wants to speak to the
amendment no one does I think it
probably go some way to meet Council M's
concerns as well that so is everyone
happy to go to the vote on that now okay
those in favor of the
amendment those against the
amendment any
extensions thank
you so that is amendment is
carried anybody else want to speak on
this
item
thank you can I just raise one question
because I think it also go backs to what
council mil was talking about we refer
to 3G artificial pictures but obviously
there's concerns as well over those
which might not be regarded as 3G
pictures like um there's been some
planning applications recently and
there's what you might call 2g or or
um I'm not sure what the word is
describing them but they're not AB that
the full standard of what we regard as
3G pitches would are we using 3G
artificial pitches as a generic term for
all artificial plastic pictures or
not sorry councelor W okay I would say
you can't I would say 3G is either 3G
and it can't be anything else and I
would say you know to be unambiguous is
something we should not
do I agree that's why I phrased it and I
think that if we're not talking
about those which might not be regarded
as 3G because most people regard 3G as a
type of pitch there's also 4G pitches I
think aren't there and there probably be
5G or or is everything now
3G so 3G covers everything as far as
we're
concerned I if you're concerned we we
you you could change it to artificial
pitches you know if you're concerned um
I mean I think we'd understand what that
means you know and if you took it in the
context of the report as well um
obviously referring to artificial
infields of SBR Plastics microplastics I
think you'd you you you draw that
conclusion but I think if you wanted
that as a as a stand line then perhaps
removing 3G just saying artificial
pitches yeah I agree with counc Ward on
that counc Ward
so so chairman in effect then you need
to take out European
Union because if you because it's the 3G
pitches that the European Union has
banned and so if you decide that you're
going to say all artificial pitches then
I'm afraid you got to take the European
Union
out sorry so uh so I think clar we say
given the European ban on the 3G
artificial pitches would remain I think
that's the context to to to the position
stat and we' carry on sale on using
tradition INF mics and the Declaration
of eological emergency by this Council
the council positions that any
artificial pitches planned for the
district should strive to or should uh
use sustainable organic materials and at
the end of the life Rec cycling of tur
proof takes place with the other
Amendment added as well I do not have
any funds me my apologies which is one
that counsil Wilson for yeah that sounds
good any other questions on
that so I'm not sure we'll be on now we
still go so is that anyone putting that
Amendment
forward or should I put that forward
from the chair I'll put it forward from
the chair and seconded by um councelor
Judy
Gooding s i I will try and read out the
whole of it now because I can't haven't
got part of
it so the draft position statement will
read
sorry given the European Union ban on 3D
artifici artificial pitches on using
traditional infill microplastics and the
Declaration of a climate and ecological
emergency by this
Council the council position is that any
artificial pitches planned for the
district should use sustainable organic
materials and that end of life recycling
of turf at approved facilities takes
place and then and that all alternativ
valuated and then the final sentence
will
read and that all alternatives to be
evaluated before considering their
use is everyone happy with that and I've
got that
correct any other
questions okay so we will go to the vote
go to the vote then all those in
favor
that was unanimous thank you I
think that's the end of that
item so we now move on
to
item
six parks for nature climate impact
report again Marcus hotton director of
environment will introduce this
report
actually I think I think Adam Aldridge
was going to introduce I'll gladly take
questions after
Adams thank you good evening members
yeah the report sets out the background
information on um continuing our parts
nature program um and the carbon
offsetting that that achieves happy to
take any questions thank
you councelor ward yeah thank you
chairman um well I know that my local
one has been well received
um there was a lot of consultation at
brockford um initially there was a wee
bit of unhappiness but uh so pleased
that our Ranger went over there our
Warden and had a long conversation and
have adapted brockford to well tailed it
to the resident's desires uh and I'm
hoping that all the others were done the
same because I think um I think this is
excellent what is going forward and I
would certainly support this the whole
way thank you um councelor Judy Gooding
and then councelor
sharp I wish I could agree with you
councilor Ward because um as the ward
counselor for um haulwell West uh
Clemens Hall um hasn't yet been added
into the list therefore I would ask for
memb support to to add this to the list
and with the view of visit officers
revisiting um with its area of meow and
Woodlands to be determined at a later
date yeah sorry were you seconding that
councelor so that's second by councel
mcferson any comments from councel W
yeah if uh if the members could please
educate me on what is the current use of
the CL whole green
space thank you um currently the green
space is used um just a recreational
area as an extension to the Leisure
Center I assume that's the reason it's
not on this particular list then because
it has other uses for the community
which is Recreation Sport and such
like
um okay Council so in formal Recreation
so it's not not formal so there's no um
football or Cricket or anything of those
likes is is a field for picnicking um
maybe a kick around but it's a large
field I think there's potential there um
but but it just needs to be
Revisited I just wanted to understand uh
the logic behind the questions from uh
the
counselors sorry councelor Gooding to
come back
I'd just like to add that there there
currently is funding available to to
renew the skate park which hasn't yet
been approved but with the funding there
we could offset some of the work that we
do with rewilding Etc and and make a
difference in that open space so there's
lots of potential because of the funding
that's available for the skate
park okay uh councelor shop was that on
the this subject on this amend
yeah okay counc M you indicate yeah I
mean I went to over to Grovewood when we
looked at having a flower Med over there
really where we're not CH chopping the
grass too much I think that would work
at Clemens H look rather and especially
if we seed it with wild flowers it
looked rather quite magical I think
certain times of the year and would go
towards this targets I support councelor
goody in that area and there I don't
think expensive thing to do either which
is the other side
of thank you okay thank you um councelor
Williams thank you chairman would it be
appropriate to ask officer's opinion on
this
please yeah I'm happy to
yeah sorry can you ask that question
again well I was just wondering your
opinion on on this proposal on if it's
if the site is worthy of that thank you
yeah of course yes of course we more
than happy to revisit the site um and
they ask our our teams to make the
arrangements and meetings and bring
something back um for the next
meeting okay thank you any oh Council
board thank you very much chairman um
the skate park will that be still
available will that still go into Clem
hall or is the skate park going to be
disposed of instead
sorry it's outside of this report but my
understanding is that the skate park
will is still being consulted on so it
won't prevent the skate park going in is
my
understanding just come back just to
clarify your
statement both would live happily
together um yeah maybe Adam alridge
would to comment I'm
um the happily uh skate parks and
Meadows being happy together seem to
just just tickle me a little um I mean
certainly they can be um they can
complement each other yeah there's
enough room there to complement each
other thank
you right thank you and councelor
sha um thank you chair I think this is a
splendid initiative I absolutely no
difficulty in supporting fully
supporting the recommendation just
wonder whether we shouldn't be putting
something about timing like as soon as
possible or by the end of the year is
that
practical yeah
Adam um yeah I mean we can plan the
majority of this has been match funded
so as as and when the funding is
available we strive to to get the
planting done within that same
year okay thank you any other
questions uh councelor Wilson thank you
chairman it's a question um for the
offices through you if I may um I think
it's a really good uh initiative and I
fully support it and I think that the
environmental benefits are great but I'm
not sure we're communicating that
um very well with the residents so I
think it's a suggestion really is how
are we're going to communicate this to
them yeah course thank you um so one
thing we do intend to do we we have a
volunteer policy up from running now
with expressions of Interest so our next
phase of planting we intend to publicize
that and welcome volunteers to come and
join us for that but I take your point
um and we will look to do some more
press and coms around the
initiative councelor mcon thank you
chairman um I just want to support what
councelor Wilson was just saying because
um our part down in Waker was one of the
first ones we had teething troubles um
and the officers listen to them they
listen to the concerns of the residents
Pathways were cutting it's been now
embedded into the community which is
lovely um but we do need to let them
know you know the benefits of this
because we've got some facts and figures
here so to get those out would be great
and it can path uh path the way for the
future parks that are going to be uh out
natured what's the
word rewilded thank you
okay thank you I agree with that as well
I know in holbridge which is why
councelor Wilson brought this up we had
residents very concerned about the the
grass being left to grow long and being
attacked by snakes and other animals
hiding in it which I think actually
there was a couple of reports but I'm
not sure how serious they were but yeah
any other questions or comments on item
six
so I just get the
recommendation so um I'm suggesting then
on if I read recommendation one we'll be
adding Clement Hall to this
recommendation because it actually lists
all the the site so I'll read this out
as it stands so the members are asked to
recommend to the executive
recommendation one to continue the roll
out of the parks for nature scheme to
complete the listed sites Bedford close
ra Rockford green ra kudan Village
greenbridge Recreation Ground morvin
Road ra mview Meadows Rochford Roth
Recreation ground Rochford Reservoir
radi Asia
Center Swain
Park and Clem's
Hall Recreation ground is it what's the
term Recreation ground sorry Marcus
that's perfectly fine yes
soor yes that's fine Clement or
Recreation recogniz uh which yeah CL
Hall Recreation
ground is that um councelor Williams
chairman did you say rord leure
Center for clarity I'll just read them
all out again that are on the list and
we and Council Gooding will double check
them against the the list on page 6.18
so we're very clear what we were
agreeing I think it
18 sorry one moment pass my list to coun
Gooding right so the listed site Bedford
toast
Ry brockford green ra can you
Canon Village greenbridge Recreation
Ground morvin Road Ry mview me Meadows
Rochford Warth Recreation ground
Rochford Reservoir rayy Leisure Senter
Swain Park and Clem
Hall is
that yeah one minute I'm just going to
confer with um the
officer
so thank you that is the list the list I
just R now coun
W yeah thank you I mean on that on the
list where we got six points fre we've
got obviously from 6.2 6.3 we've got the
implemented sites and then on 6.3 going
down we've got those waiting for
implementation um there are two sites on
there which come up as question marks
basically lower land bricks which is now
not viable which has been taken out but
the other one uh again is uh on hold
which is R leure open
space so um as long as that's noted that
that's in there
because we did mention ra
Leisure and that is on hold at the
[Music]
moment Marcus hton I
think thank you s I think um reg Li
Center um there has been a roll out of
the parks of nature um I think that's we
refer to in R open space
is is that the one you're referring to
council sorry I'm just reading your
report and I'm commenting on the report
so I just wanted
clarification soorry yes so part of uh R
Leg Center was rolled out with the long
grass grass um the rewelding the grass
Meadows um but the rest of the project
is on the hold so that would it would
stop any tree planted at the moment if
that makes sense
sorry okay thank you um I've got some
advice which we'll take the amendment
separately but councelor mcferson
first sorry chairman um just South End
Road Memorial Gardens and my
understanding is a community group of
looking to take that on and it will be
more of a formal Garden than a
rewilding if officers can
confirm so obviously the report writes
to the Asis situation rather than so of
course things can can occur in the
future but that that would be part of a
separate report future report thank you
okay thank you um I've been advised we
need to take the um adding of amendment
Clement's Hall as an amendment to the
list in R1 so that's been proposed by
councelor Gooding and seconded by coun
MC councelor mcferson so any further
questions on this amendment adding
Clement h no so we go straight to the
vote all those in
favor thank you that's
unanimous so do you want me to read this
out for the fourth time I will just for
or I'll be happy to take it that I've
read it out enough
times okay so we now go to vote on
recommendation one which I've read out
earlier with now the added Amendment so
all those in favor of recommendation one
thank you again that's
unanimous right agenda item seven
Financial appraisal of R District
council's 2030 net zeroc carbon Target
again Marcus hotton Direct dor of
environment will introduce the
report uh thank you a great deal of work
has gone into this report um I think
we've got uh our climate and
sustainability manager Henry mus here to
uh introduce and take questions on a bit
more the detail so I'll hand over to him
thank
you
I just introduce the recommendations
yeah so the the port is essentially
looking as to whether or net0 2030
Target for carbon emissions Associated
directly with the council is feasible
and to try and give a timeline of
different interventions and costs which
will be
involved and what funding is available
and uh what we could bid for for
Grants
so essentially
U that's all mapped out and the three
recommendations to consider um to
achieve the 93% reduction against that
Target which is quite impressive because
we've still got six years so it's quite
comforting that we are well on target to
hit the
target uh is to explore a
green tariff which essentially is carbon
free electricity for our corporate
corporate sites which we're not doing
yet that's really a quick win and may
not even be a cost implication just a
switch of
tariff uh to look into the hydrotreated
vegetable oil which is the green or
renewable
diesel which is a significant proportion
of the carbon footprint for
Rochford another quick win really in
terms of investment and that's been
captured in terms of Lifetime costs to
save a ton of
CO2 and then
there's the the ask to consider the
allocation of three4 of a million pounds
uh for the other measures pending
results of um grants funding
Etc any questions thank you any
questions councilor
Ward yeah thank you chair um I there's a
couple of things just want to understand
in regards to especially recommendation
two um that's quite a large additional
cost which is going to come out over a
period of the recommendation for the
time of the use of the waste vehicles uh
to about
600,000 uh which is quite a large
commitment now I I know from a political
point of view um there may be looking at
the reduction down to Net Zero or carbon
zero in 2030 but the government have
moved the golf post now to
2035 now I wonder uh I'm just looking at
this extra money of taxpayers money and
new vehicles are coming in uh I've I've
had a look at a lot of the stuff that's
going on in California and I've looked
at a lot I've spoken to Toyota as well
uh because I was involved in the many
years back and they're bringing on the
hydrogen engines uh they've already got
one on the market now uh trucks are now
available in uh us for transportation it
works out a lot cheaper now I'm just
wondering are we are we spending a lot
of money now it's it it it may just be a
political decision uh something that
people want to do to actually reduce
this down and it may be that's the way
they want to go okay but I'm just want
to
challenge that amount of money and maybe
there is a moment in time that we need
to think very clearly that if we're
going to change over the vehicles the
vehicles are going to be changed over
that I would rather see that money saved
for other
uses that particular amount of money
saved for other uses the other things to
discuss in R3 with regard to solar and
other
mitigating items I'm happy with it's
just that one item I want to challenge
because of the change of vehicles we we
can see in the report that there is not
a consideration for electric that's been
discounted within the report and I
totally agree with that um but I think
the the consideration of moving to
hydrogen Vehicles is very viable and I'm
just wondering if you know that amount
of talent I'm looking at where we live
we live in um an environment which is
rural we have lots of trees which will
absorb a lot of the
CO2 we're not living in the midst of
London where unfortunately there's not
enough trees there to absorve that so
I'm just looking at that particular item
to challenge the
viability of that item thank
you thank you Council Lord um so for
realityy um the HBO fuel is a direct
diesel replacement so um it is something
that can almost be um on tap or off can
put on tap that makes sense so you can
um if you wish to go back to normal dies
we can go back to De with the same
vehicle so it's a revenue commitment
rather than than a capital but it's also
a route to Net Zero um that we can take
at any time on that on that period of
years so I I recognize in the future
there may be better Technologies I think
what we've mapped out at the moment is a
way to achieve 93% reduction in our
carbon emissions over that period it's
it's a Roots I think it's it's setting
out the principles of how that could be
achieved I think you're right to ask
those questions um around sort of
hydrogen powered vehicles I think
they're again we we follow that with
interest too um I think at this stage
the central government is still fairly
um lukewarm on on supporting to many
initiatives and it's still in its
infancy so I think what we're sing at
this stage is that that it's something
that can be considered so if you wish to
achieve Net Zero um quickly as a council
therefore it's a um option to consider
but it doesn't
um um I'm R Roll Out Future options so
you know if you wish to go back you
could even mix half and half half Diesel
half
hvo it's a straightforward replacement
so our existing Vehicles can can almost
you know run off that straightway so yes
of course you run it for the fourth
period of that time it is that cost um
but equally um if you wish to start on
year five or year six on St you could go
across at that stage so so it's not a a
commitment that you cannot reverse if
that makes sense so I wouldn't say
you're locked in at
all yeah um councelor M did you indicate
earlier
did
it is actually
yeah well my understanding that the the
additional £84,000 is the difference
between the current cost of uh Diesel
and hydrotreated vegetable oil and if
one look sort of projects forward
there's every chance the cost of diesel
will go up and the cost of hydro treated
vegetable oil will get will go down
going forward so I think that it isn't
necessarily going to be £84,000 it could
be a lesser figure going forward and my
bet that it would
be okay thank you um Council
mcferson thank you chairman um my
questions relate and um observations
relate to recommendation three to
consider the allocation of the uh well
751 th000 of capital funding to deliver
the energy saving Improvement to the
council's assets as set out in the
report um one thing that I think that
everybody should note um this report
doesn't include all the
assets it quite clearly takes The
Freight House and South Street out of
this now I will give you a scenario if
we're looking to reduce our carbon
footprint we could probably actually
demonstrate that as a counil by selling
those assets overnight but that's not
going to actually reduce their carbon
footprint we will just pass it on to
somebody else to deal with so I do think
if we're doing a review of our assets we
should do a review of all of our
assets that's one point would you like
me to answer that one now y because
there's quite a clear answer to that one
at the moment unfortunately which
is The Freight
House the Civic
suite and South Street aren't mentioned
because there is no determination made
to what is happening there's still the
original agreement is still in place
then there is an an asset delivery
program that's yet to be decided
unfortunately it's taken longer than we
would have wanted but obviously as a new
Administration it it's taken us time to
to understand what's going on so just
because they're on they're not here
because we have made no decision on them
at this
point Thank You chairman I I I take that
on board however um we have got the mill
included in here as well and until
there's a meaningful market
research returned I don't know unless
you know otherwise that the future is
confirmed for that building as well so
it could sit the same as our other
assets if anybody wants to answer that
one I'm happy to answer that in the L an
officer wants to but the um as far as
well the M hold is open and running and
we are currently looking to what
operating model will be taking forward
with the m Hall but whatever operating
model we take
forward will have the
advantage of this work being done to it
to make it cheaper to run I think in a
recent meeting it was stated that the
net operating cost of the M hor is
£340,000 so if we bring that down which
this would do so it's not just a carbon
saving we're making here it's a cost
saving as well the cost saving will make
it more attractive as an as any
operating model whether it's internal or
external to an
operator thank you chairman but just to
say again um our Leisure centers they
probably would be um green we're not
going to be um moving them in any other
direction from where they are um the
mill hole is still under observation on
how it will um work and fund going
forward um The Freight House
unfortunately is very similar to the
mhor community center that's been lost
for that Community it should be included
in here and I I will stick to my guns on
that one and have to abstain from
recommendation three um and then just
looking at page
7.8
6.2 it does say the request for the
additional 751 th000 capital is not part
of the council's existing Capital
program and would have to be considered
within the upcoming budget setting cycle
for the next Municipal
Year and that also concerns me because
where are we going to get that funding
from our taxpayer or
realignment thank
you so the I mean so
it's it's I want say desktop exercise
but clearly
um we we have to set out a route to to
to to prove that it can be achieved um
where the funding is found is a
different matter um and we we're saying
it's we recommend to the executive to
consider and I think I think as officers
I think I think speaking to the chair as
well that we recognize the funding is
necessarily there but it but it
establishes the principles I think
that's that's the key thing so if we're
saying actually we recognize this is a
route to to um or route to near carbon
net zero that's as an authority we're
we're um um content to follow and as a
principal we're content to follow this
then I think it's then for officers
perhaps them to go away and say you know
how can we find this funding and that's
the next stage but what I least want to
know as initial thing is yes we believe
this is this is the right way to achieve
that so of course 750,000 cannnot be
taken lightly um but then you know the
next stage after this will be to of
course for officers to seek funding but
I would also argue some of this is
actually um there's a compelling case
for investor save yeah would that be so
I would probably go away you know want
to pre the executive but they may well
say there is no money at this stage but
but even with investor save it could be
we could borrow or we could find grants
but but there are other ways of
recognizing that that that sort of
Target thank you may come back thank you
could I just add one more thing sorry c
one thing we obviously we're not sitting
here doing nothing and obviously Henry
mus particularly is out there looking
for Grants and I'm aware whether we have
applied for a grant in relation to Clem
Hall which we were hoping to have some
news on in about four to six weeks
possibly I've mentioned that many times
before we're waiting for the result for
that for that bid thank
you thank you chairman and um I was
literally going to come back to say the
officers reassured me financially
especially around the investor save
principles um my still my only concern
is that not all this is a great start
but I'd love to see all assets included
in there even if it was in a stage
process thank
you yeah thank you I'm sure you'll be
questioning me closely tomorrow night on
it as well along with Tim Willis thank
you councelor m yeah given the pressure
on the midterm Financial strategy
looking at recommendation two which as
as marus says we can Implement down the
line if we wish
um and the fact that all of our assets
are not
listed uh wouldn't it be more prudent to
as as we resolve the issues to do with
our assets that we do include everything
that is in in that area and look at this
84,000 a year because we can use that
money in the shorter term to get the
pressure off of actually developing and
making these assets um really invol
environmentally friendly and well
insulated and so on with the right kind
of uh Heating and all the rest of it um
and it gives the maybe some building
work to be done and so on so and then at
a later stage we could switch to um an
alternative to to Mineral diesel um
because let's face it I know it's
cleaner but it still creates CO2 so we
haven't got the clean vehicles yet as
Council W has said so from that point of
view if we did it that way wouldn't we I
know we're we're not hitting our Target
then because we're moving of that graph
but you know to to look at
recommendation to and actually hold back
on that to get Finance really for these
other things that need
doing that's my
[Music]
question again it's for you as a
committee to decide I think as a climate
an an ecological emergency committee um
where I think you know you've declared a
climate emergency said there there is
this imperative to
achieve this as quickly as possible then
I my view the spirit of the committee
would be such that I'm suggesting this
the quickest and most cost effective way
to achieve that um and it's then for
then when this is presented to the
executive it's for the executive to
consider other wider matters and
pressures but I think you know within
this so see we're almost thinking
outside of of of this committee this
committee about how can we achieve this
target Target and and and we set out a
route I fully agree what youest
absolutely if you if you get the capital
investment first achieve the savings and
the savings can then fund the fuel um is
probably a solution that that seems very
neat um but if you but but I think from
an officer perspective certainly from
from sort of sustainability T if we H at
you there is a quick way of achieving
this it comes at a cost you might but
why didn't you tell us that so we we've
set it out in this way absolutely that
that maybe when it gets to Executive
they want to take a different view or
you could take a different view this
evening but be know but I think you know
from our point my perspective we've set
out the quickest way we think we can
achieve this the most coste effective
way the funding is a challenge but
perhaps that's more for executive to
consider than than than the committee
tonight but that's entirely up to you
thank you sorry could I just that come
back as well and just say that the whole
point of hpo is it does reduce CO2 I
think was it by 93% overall of our use
yeah sorry C you want to come back
anyway no no no that's
all I know a bit about combustion
sorry anybody else got any
comments
concerns no so sorry Council F you want
to shall we I'm happy to take the
recommendations separately so people can
vote on them separately because I think
there's a bit of um con concern on some
of them from some people so I
will read them from the
chair and we'll take them in turn I
will propose each one and then I I'll
just need a second for each one okay
thank you so I'll start with
recommendation one recommendation one to
explore a green zeroc carbon electricity
tariff for the council corporate
supplies
councilor sharp seconds it so we go to
the vote those in
favor sorry those
against none against and those
abstentions thank you one
abstention thank you so recommendation
one is
carried
recommendation
two to consider the allocation of an
additional £84,000 Revenue budget for
the purchase of the procurement of green
diesel hydr treated vegetable oil for
the council Fleet currently using
mineral
diesel right those in
favor those
against none against those abstaining
one abstention thank
you that also was
carried recommendation three to consider
the allocation of £750,000
973 of capital funding to deliver energy
saving improvements to council assets
ass set out in the
report I'm again moving that and that's
seconded by councilor Wilson
um those in
favor okay those
against any
extensions four four okay thank you
that's
carried
thank you we now move on to agenda item
8 sustainability progress report again
this report will be presented by marus
hton director of
environment thank you so this is a a
brief report really just summarizing the
progress made this year uh against the
sustainability strategy and um the
targets that were agreed by the
committee earlier this year so the idea
is that this will go back into um
Council be a regular report and so we've
keep kept it fairly brief and Punchy but
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you any
questions no I can't see anyone I'm
indicating thank you for the report I
think
again it's useful to have this to make
sure we're on Target and making sure
we're not forgetting anything from the
sustainability report that is ex
excellent so if there's no questions
I'll go straight to the vote I'll read
out the
recommendation there is only one
recommendation recommendation
one to approve the contents of the
report for presentation to the next
available council
meeting oh councilor m is moving that
yes um I think councelor um Gooding is
seconding that all those in
favor
thank you that was
unanimous um that concludes the business
for this evening's meeting it has closed
at
827 p.m. thank you very
much